do have one of our favorite guests here
on the show and we have a kitty rackleff
with us to talk about explore st. Louis
and all the amazing things there are to
do in st. Louis outside of visiting the
Hall of Fame in the club and she's with
Maurice yes we are with Kitty Radcliffe
who's one of my favorite guests here as
she always extolled the virtues of her
great city st. Louis he welcome back to
the show thank you it's great to be here
never see you in February because the
championships are either sometime in the
spring in April the US Championships or
the Sinquefield Cup but now we are in
February what's there to do here in the
wintertime other than worry about polar
vortex is deciding oh well the polar
vortex is something we can all enjoy
because we can go out and go ice-skating
there are great ice skating rinks all
over town including one right just a
couple blocks from here at Forest Park
so it's a great way to enjoy the
outdoors as well a lot of our visitor
attractions have wonderful events for
outside the in in the wintertime as well
as extraordinary events going on in the
museums and the cultural institutions in
the winter well I'm a Jamaican born boy
I still got the heat in me and so I'm
not gonna go ice skating it's too cold
give me some specific activities
happening this month that folks if they
decide to come down could enjoy indoors
indoors well it does it does explain now
why I haven't run into you on the street
here because normally I run into you on
the street but not not in February no I
need to go for a walk in the park
30 degrees I said I would love to if it
was 30 degrees warmer but you're on your
own sister so what could Irina and I
share to Brooklynites if we want to go
see something happening in st. Louis now
well wonderful musical offerings the st.
Louis Symphony Orchestra jazz st. Louis
the black rep the Repertory Theater all
I mean they they all have wonderful
productions going on right now
and you know that's those are mostly
things that one would want to do perhaps
on like a Friday night or Saturday night
or Sunday matinee and so the weekends
are kind of filled with musical musical
offerings this time of year
extraordinary exhibits that some of our
some of our museums there's been a
wonderful kind of wild
wilee exhibit at the st. Louis Art
Museum
that's just finishing up so people have
just collected the last few days in
order to be able to see that the
Contemporary Art Museum has a great
exhibit right now as does the Pulitzer
and for those that are interested in
sporting events the Blues hockey games
are here and you know there's a lot of
great fans who've loved hockey
struggling maybe the chip the tickets
are a little cheaper now the Blues have
struggled a little
I heard the Billikens over there the
Billikens our st. Louis University's
basketball team they've also been
struggling a little bit right now so
yeah there's some good tickets available
a lot of cheers going on when the Rams
lost the Super Bowl yes I know the Rams
it was kind of silent because I think a
lot of people weren't actually watching
the Super Bowl in st. Louis well a year
from now when this event is back here in
February next year there will be a
different brand of football playing here
in February we are gonna be welcoming
one of the first XFL teams to for a new
start up football league that will begin
in February of 2020 and we'll go through
the end of April so they will play in
non NFL season and as soon as the Super
Bowl ends yeah so we're looking forward
to that the guy who created the whole
Wrestlemania Enterprise his name is
Vincent McMahon he's starting this new
football league so I think it will be as
much entertainment as it is football
fascinating Chompy this event is
different from any that has ever been
done in the United States and the
highest-rated of female event in history
on US soil and you get to have it here
and st. Louis
that make you feel as I say in Louisiana
pride well to have all the the top women
players from around the world in our
community is an extraordinary thing for
us and it's it's great to have it saying
this is a great city for women leaders
you know our mayor's is a woman that our
Airport director is a woman the head of
the history museum as a woman and a lot
of the cultural institutions the head of
the symphony as a woman Marie Helen
Barnard and so there are a lot of great
women leaders in this community and so
it's it's wonderful to embrace women's
leadership in all aspects and forms and
to have the top female players from
around the globe in our community is
really wonderful they almost didn't
invite me and Yasser back they let us in
the door finally the Gateway Arch is
well I heard ed mentioned the grounds
are open now all the the 380 million
dollar project was finished this past
year in 2018 so that did everything
everything from the new museum to all
kinds of work on the grounds and people
were coming from all over the world to
see it and then of course our federal
government had a shutdown so the arch
grounds were actually closed for 35 days
but they are reopened and available for
everyone to see excellent well thank you
so much for all the great work you do
touting st. Louis always fun to have you
here look forward to next time it's nice
to be here
thank you dear a cliff over everybody
the president of explore st. Louis a
great town if you want to come see some
chess and a lot of other things as well